الطواقم
الطبيه تحاول اخراج شهداء وجرحى
[ضحك]
الان هذه الساحه بداخلها مئات المواطنين
النازحين وتم قصف هذه البنايه المقابله
للمستشفى اي على باب المستشفى تماما هؤلاء
الشهداء الان يتم اخراجهم من القصف
الاسرائيلي
اتجاه المستشفى وهم من
النازحين هنا ايضا قسم الاستقبال والطوارء
ممتل تماما بالاصابات
والمواطنين الذين جاؤوا للتعرف على من
اصيب ومن استشهد في هذه الغاره الجويه
الاسرائيليه
هذه الاصابات والشهداء في كل مكان في قسم
الاستقبال لا يوجد متسع تماما الان في
المستشفى بسبب هذه المجزره الجديده هنا
اطباء وهنا ايضا مسعفين كانوا اثناء عملهم
على باب المستشفى قد اصيبوا
بجراح كل المصابين هم من المدنيين من
النازحين الذين كانوا في ساحه المستشفى
يجلسون وفجاه قصفت الطائرات ايش اللي صار
انا وا جبت
الخدم انفجار على الباب عندي الاسعاف اللي
حماني انا الاسعاف
الطريق سح اول ثاني
ثالث بطله اج وستشهد 15 ولا
ثلاث 15 بون في لي بنات ضايعين في بنت
ومعها بها صغيره عندا بتحطها في لاجين
بدور عليها في شهيده مش لاقياها وجوزها
نقطع اجب ودورت على اجب في مكان ثاني
الناس هم من النازحين الذين كانوا جاؤوا
ليحتموا بمستشفى شهداء الاقصى ولكن الغاره
الاسرائيليه كانت على باب المستشفى وقد
اصيب عدد كبير من المواطنين هنا في هذه
الغاره الجويه اه هات هات